article 13 has passed everyone
what we feared all along has become
a reality the internet as we know it is
gone it's obviously really upsetting i
think a lot of people don't know what's
gonna happen
but people have been saying things like
now memes will be banned
now all this content from europe will be
banned youtube have been saying that
they might remove content completely
from eu it's obviously a big change
coming
and that's why i have a great deal for
you guys
[Music]
honestly we didn't know that article 13
was gonna pass but
i've teamed up with nordvpn which is an
amazing vpn i use it myself
article 13 gets passed myvpn
this is america that's right there's a
simple solution to all this article 13
mumbo jumbo
vpns baby in case you don't know a vpn
lets you browse the internet
as if you were anywhere almost anywhere
in the world
jokes on you european legislation i
don't understand
so norvpn it's a great service you can
use it on your even on your phone
it's super simple to use and right now
we have a great deal
that you don't get just 50 percent off
you don't get 100 off
you get 75 up if you enter the code
pewdiepie nordvpn.com says pewdiepie
it's only 299
a month that's a great price i mean
honestly that is pretty cheap and you
get one month for free
because you enter the code pewdiepie so
good for you what a way to troll the
european union
there's obviously other reasons to use a
vpn especially for security reasons
what you don't care about internet
security what a loser
pathetic okay you need to care about
these things you know
all your data could easily be stolen
just like that
if you have a vpn it's protected it's
protection thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring this video
and now let's get on with it
[Music]
welcome all new subscribers
ever since this t-series versus
pewdiepie thing my channel has just
been abundantly inflated with
subscribers but really
this is it it's just me in a bedroom
looking at stuff on the internet
i want that to be clear here i don't
want there to be any higher expectations
this is all that we're doing we're gonna
go ha ha over
a bunch of clips today now since we have
so many new subscribers i decided to
create this new show
called july you lose we're testing this
out
it's please be patient uh we will see
how it goes
but basically the rule is simple you
live you lose
let's freaking go
hey look it's me it starts with me t
series
35 years how long does trash live
thousand years
we don't need to cry anymore we are
winning that's right everyone i don't
know if we still are
it's ironic how we made the
congratulations song to
wrap up the meme to stop the meme oh god
oh they're playing congratulations now
great
we finally did it we we persuaded nine
year olds from saying
tj to congratulations instead amazing
well done come back of the goddamn
century
we'll go for another thousand years
another millennium
easy
[Music]
monty
no no no no
[Music]
okay
i jesus christ
i still haven't watched jojo but i feel
like with all the memes it will just
never live up to the expectation
low quality yet hi dear
oh it's another one of these huh
who will it oh doctor phil
dr phil kawaitisney sugoi
edith
he's so beautiful absolute beautiful man
i miss him
you know i miss seeing him i miss making
video of him
i wake up sometimes at night wet
thinking about
dr phil well
well guess i'm going to sew it myself
what the heck what's going on
oh that's funny do people buy those
cookies just to
put their [ __ ] in and why are they so
convenient
to use for sewing stuff pathetic
what is happening here what is this oh
no oh
it's beautiful
[Music]
see all these life skills that parents
try and
emit upon their children that is never
going to give them anything
in life beyond just random memes i
really appreciate that
you know this kid had to go to like
thousands of dollars of lessons
just led up to this moment oh no i mean
i'm sure it's not that hard to play but
still
no no kid wakes up one day like i want
to play that
big weird guitar looking instrument
cello is that what it's called no it's
shut up i know what it's called never
touch jimmy
fallon's hand you okay you played the
piano laying upside down you were laying
on the ground playing
with your hands crossed what's gonna
happen oh sorry yeah yeah
please his other ones no no no no that
that was something freddy did
what happened at one point played the
piano laying upside down you were laying
on the ground playing
with your hands crossed spoiler alert oh
sorry yeah yeah
there's other ones no no no no that that
was something freddy did
jimmy always laughs what happened jimmy
why was that not funny
looked like he just got his whole life
ruined another three month of heavy
drinking memory wipe therapy gone
so he has second emotion besides
laughter
at one point who would have thought so
that's the most surprising i just
assumed
no no no that was something freddy did
i've never seen another emotion from
this man
[Music]
oh my god hey it's this one
oh that's creepy
[Music]
dr
hey what the [ __ ]
oh it's piece of us okay okay i got it
okay that's funny i still haven't seen
that movie
oh that's that actually makes a lot of
sense now now it's a joke
logan tell me you did not just hit him
lucas did logan hit you
[Music]
don't take man's waffle wait logan took
his waffles logan's house oh well that
changed his name
lucas did logan hit you really
he ate his waffle oh that's totally
justified then
don't eat logan's waffle everyone knows
this never touch
logan's waffle i really expected it to
be uh i did not hit her i did not
no just me okay moving on
oh yes oh well
[Music]
it's these jokes i you know they're
coming
you know exactly what the joke is but it
still makes you laugh
because god damn if a good old scratch
that isn't worth it
oh my god oh wow
yeah whoa
oh my god is he drugged
what is happening your cat is a thought
i like this i just look at the comment
pewdiepie is losing dumb
start subscribing thank you fabulous
bacon
for doing your part
it's everywhere i look now still there
hold on oh damn
oh jesus
okay
is
back
oh my god oh my god
that's insane how is that real god damn
just the beginning
it was amazing
[Applause]
god damn that was amazing i mean it
wasn't funny but it still made me laugh
i guess that means i lose a life oh no
what am i possibly gonna do awkward
disney channel
wand ids with graphics hey
wait what is this from lizzie mcguire
and you're watching disney channel
and they're laughing too what is this
this is real
let's do one more hey i'm hillary duff
from
one more for
this is out takes and someone decided to
draw over the eyes
i'm raven that's so raven and you're
watching disney channel let's see the
mouse
wow incred whoa
hi i'm david from that's the raven and
you're watching disney channel
oh wow oh wow disney channel oh
oh wow wow
hi i'm annelise and you're watching the
disney channel
[Laughter]
i'm really excited okay all right let's
see let's see if i can do it
it's a part of you but exploring is not
a game
is this dora the explorer look before
you leave
it's like a fan made one maybe is this
real i'm okay boots
so goddamn bad well at least i didn't
laugh god damn
sans meme in 2019 jesus christ when will
your kids laugh
i knew it mom we're buying an xbox
controller
and we my mom is not even here i don't
know why i
said that unbelievable
[Music]
oh god yes have i seen this resident
evil 2 but
1 000 facial animations
[Music]
okay two hundred percent okay oh
i believe you buddy i believe you it
just
percent from the bar there's one side
that's how i eat all right
all right all right thousand percent
let's go
that's a tasty burger right
us a story there it's not too bad
the burger just that good that your
whole face melts
hey look it's another pig right the only
stuff that makes me laugh
mama are you subscribed to pewdiepie no
i'm going to live with dad good
as you should get your mom and make her
to subscribe
right freaking now i'm waiting hi mom
subscribe please thanks did that work
incredible
almost all nine year olds have a mom
right if we can get all the
nine-year-olds mom to subscribe
then we have double subscribers all
right that was it for this week's
your life you lose smash like if you
liked and smash like if you lose
and i see your broskis tomorrow you
remember
check out merch check out merch remember
that a hundred million very nice look at
this merge
support the channel see you guys
tomorrow bye
what tuber simulator is becoming
relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes
ah this game is still relevant
god dammit